all right just cuz I don't look enough
like a dork normally BAM this is 3d
technology now people have been
promising us this for decades but we
have yet to really implement into our
home but thankfully Samsung is totally
jumping on that ball so an all their
0708 DLP's they have this technology
which you can for two hundred dollars
you can buy the software you put it on
your computer then with maybe like a DVI
to hdmi adapter you hook it into the TV
and then boom you have 3d they sing at
these glass not these glasses they
actually send you cooler ones so anyway
what you do is you put them on and you
watch in 3d the way it works that they
basically vibrate the images at 120
frames per second and they alternate
back and forth at 60 frames per second
on each eye so it gives you the the
perception of depth but I think the
coolest thing for most people that are
going to find with this is that there's
a dual view setup so a lot of people
have played video games and then you
have to split screen and you can see
what that guy's doing and he can see
what you're doing and it's not as fun so
with dual view when you each have a pair
of these on you can't see the other guy
because it's firing off each of you 60
frames per second so all you see is
yourself and then you get shot in the
face you go where did that come from and
the guy next to you shot you in the face
so that I think it's totally cool so for
the world of gaming I think this is
pretty huge news and I think this is
going to be one of the big things to
come out of CES certainly for the next
year we'll see this implemented more I
know that some of the major gaming
platforms are talking about implementing
3ds but Samsung has certainly done it
and I'm really appreciating this so I'm
gonna go and watch a meet the robinsons
because I'm 12
you